[Music]
welcome everyone to today's
webinar we're going to talk about
reproducible examples
from a conceptual point of view and why
they're
surprisingly important and then also a
great deal
from a mechanical point of view how to
make
your reproducible examples in a way that
they're easy to share
with other people
okay so this short link the r stood
dot io rep rex currently points
to a copy of these slides on speaker
deck
another very relevant url is
repress.tideyverse.org which is
the website for the package i'm going to
talk about
and we may change what the upper
short link links to as a result of this
webinar because we're pretty excited to
get
some of these materials captured but i
promise it will always point to
something
very relevant to this package that will
link to absolutely everything else and
you're also going to see that short link
many many times during this presentation
and as said in the intro uh this video
will also be posted within 48 hours and
all of these things will be
publicized and this is my license
okay so the first thing i want to do is
show
basic usage and we're just going to get
right into it
and then we'll unpack what you just saw
so i'm actually going
to leave my slides and go over to our
studio
so i'm sitting here in an rstudio
session
it's fresh and i have a little bit of
code
up here in my source editor i'm going to
make
a factor x a factor y
i'm going to combine them and and get
what to most of us is
kind of a puzzling result so this is
just going to be an example of
a small piece of code that maybe
you want to talk about on the community
site
or share with your local our expert and
ask like what's going on
so this is how you would use rep rex to
turn this little snippet of code into a
reproducible example
this is the path of least resistance
we'll talk about other methods
later so i would select a little piece
of code
and copy it to my clipboard
then over in the r console
i'm going to type rep rex
and you will see that that little piece
of code is
run and then basically a beautiful
attractive version of that
is stored on my clipboard and i can
preview it here
so if i were to
paste the contents of my clipboard right
now
you actually see what's called markdown
and this is what's necessary to create
the attractive version of this code
and why is this helpful because you can
go
to places like github
the r studio community site or stack
overflow
and paste this markdown in so i'm going
to show you
what this would look like in a github
issue so that's that same markdown that
you just saw
github lets you preview things and
you'll see that it looks
just the way it did locally for me it's
been rendered
it's syntax highlighted we have a tiny
little ad
down here that tells people how you did
this and i could
submit that as a github issue
so that is the basic
process and the reason i can just type
repress
is that i always have
this package attached and
so you might need to call this and we're
going to talk a great deal about that
next so that is what basic
rep rex usage looks like it creates
a small little piece of code renders it
nicely
and it's ready to paste into other
formats
so this is just a static version of what
we just did
and this is the gif that i use on the
ref rex website i rewatched this clip
it's from a movie called jerry maguire
it's still highly recommended
um and basically the reason for
bothering to do
all of this is if you're going somewhere
to have a conversation about our
to have questions answered or to
describe a bug in
software um being careful about how you
make your reproducible example
makes it much much much easier for other
people to help you
and i want to explain where this word
came from repress
so roman first tweeted this and i
thought it was just
a great made up word so it is short for
reproducible
example so it is a completely made-up
word
um but it's just very handy
and i'm going to use the word rep rex
over and over and over again in this
webinar
so i want to be very clear that i'm
using it
in i'd say three like distinct but
related ways
so i think people at least in in the
small r community are starting to say
rep rex just as a noun like it is a
reproducible example
and that has nothing to do with whether
you use this package or not
but then today's webinar is going to
show you
use of a package with that same name
rep-rex that you can install from crayon
i'll show you how to do that in just a
moment
and then this is a pretty small package
it has
a couple functions but really the main
function it has
is also called rep rex so this webinar
is going to talk about how to use the
rep rex function
inside the rep rex package to produce a
good looking
reproducible example
and when does this come up in your life
it's very handy for conversations that
you have
on community.rtstudio.com
it's very handy for preparing questions
or answers
for stack overflow uh
it's very handy for reporting bugs or
making feature requests
for an r package that is developed on
github
and also very useful for having
detailed conversations about r in slack
or in email
so a reproducible example conceptually
is useful in all of those
places and then this package rep rex um
smooths over some of the mechanics
so here i want to talk to you about what
you're going to need to do
on your computer to make this package
available to yourself
so rep rex does not come with r it does
not come with our studio
you have to make an explicit effort to
install it
so you should pick one of these methods
and it's the type of thing that you do
once per computer
so you could use install.packages
open quote repress close quote to
install
just the repress package it is also
part of the meta package that we call
tidy verse
so if you did install that packages tidy
verse
rep rex would be one of the many
packages that get installed on your
machine
in general there is very little harm
that you can do to yourself by
reinstalling packages so you also should
not stress out too much
about um you know you could you could
install just reprox and then install the
tidy verse and nothing bad will happen
so do it once per machine
just because that's the minimum you need
to do but it's no tragedy if you
reinstall things
once you've installed you still need to
use our sort of library
call to make the rep rex functions
available in your r
session so you would need to do this
in every r session that you plan to use
rep rex in
so that might be something that you do
multiple times per day
certainly way way way way more than once
per computer
so every time you want to use the
package you'll need to uh
execute the library rep rex command
now i use revx several times a day
for the most part and so that would be
very annoying
so an alternative if you also become a
semi-heavy user of this package
is to make it available to yourself all
the time
so you can control the startup behavior
of r
uh through a file called dot r profile
and
conventionally it's found in your home
directory
and so uh this snippet of code suppress
messages require rep rex
looks a little different from what you
just saw but it's
sort of a better way to attach this
package uh in your
in your startup file so um you would put
this snippet of code
there in your r profile and then
forevermore
when you start r uh the rep rex package
would be available and if you have never
thought about your r profile file before
there is a function in the use this
package which you would also have to
install
that will create it for you if you don't
have it or if you do have it it would
open it for you for editing
in case you wanted to put something like
this snippet
in there so once you've done those two
things you've installed it
and you've attached it through either
the library
command or by putting something in your
r profile you are ready to use the
repress function
and what you saw me do in that first
demo was i actually
called the rep rex function explicitly
in the r console and something you'll
see me do before we're done
is we also have put some what are called
r studio add-ins into this package
that give you even more ways to launch
this function
and i this is a bit of a sidebar but
but since i have shown you how to put
things
in your r profile file i also want
to tell you how to do that responsibly
so rep rex is a workflow package
it's something you would use in your
daily work to make your life a little
bit easier you use it
interactively i would be pretty shocked
to see it show up
in a typical person's r scripts
or markdown files packages or shiny apps
and so the fact that it doesn't show up
in those things it's an interactive
package
makes it safe to attach in your our
profile
but i don't want you to get the wrong
idea and think oh my god i should do
this with all my packages
uh so i i would not want to see this
kind of code
using like dplyr ggplot2 or things that
do show up in your scripts
and it's because your scripts would then
become
highly not self-contained and they
they would work for you because of stuff
in your r profile but they won't work
for other people
so this is an interesting technique to
know about but you need to be
really really careful about what you do
here
so i think it's safe to put rep rex in
there it is not safe to put deploy r in
there
okay so we're going to get back to the
package and to reproducible examples now
so i wanted to give a brief intro like
what on earth in my life drove me to
make this
one of my missions before i joined our
studio
i was a professor at the university of
british columbia
and i had a course called stat545
that has a lot of content online to this
day the course continues you could go
there
and i ran this course entirely on github
and so it meant that all of my dialogue
with
students both sort of me to the whole
class
and and me talking to individual
students
took place in github issues and i
actually
analyzed my github usage in the course
and i found
that every fall i was participating in
at least 300 maybe 500 github issue
threads and that's just in my teaching
life
so i spend a great deal of time talking
about r in those places
and solving people's r problems
and to do that well i actually wanted to
use
executable r code and the friction
involved in making that
look good started to drive me crazy
and now that i'm no longer a full-time
faculty member
and working full-time on our packages uh
this just gives you a sense of the
intensity of my
github activity over the last year so
now i
still work with tons and tons of github
issues you know in a different capacity
and then i also
talk about r a lot in slack so i still
have this
sort of hourly need to run little pieces
of our code
and share what i'm seeing with other
people
so trying to remove friction for myself
and other people
led me to create a few principles
that i knew had to be true of a tool to
make this easier so this is the
rep rex philosophy
i think that conversations about code
are much more productive
if they contain three things well it's
one thing but three properties
code that actually runs
okay code that i do not have to run
as the reader but code
that i can easily run and so there is a
little bit of self
contradiction here but the point is you
want to make it
easy for people to interact with your
reproducible example
in a whole bunch of different ways they
can just be a consumer they can just
read it or they can easily grab it and
run it themselves
modify it and share that back with you
so i want to be really detailed about
what i mean
when i say code that actually runs so
you're going to isolate
a little piece of our code and you hand
it off to rep rex
you've seen one demo we're about to do a
whole bunch more
that code is taken and it is run in a
completely
new r session and that means it has to
be
completely self-contained so it must
include the command to load all
necessary packages
and it must create all necessary objects
and this can be very frustrating for
people but it's extremely
important so i'm going to go do this
live to show exactly what i mean
so um i'm looking at a
an r script that contains the code you
just saw on that slide
and i'm going to restart r
so let's imagine like a typical
interactive r
session so i'm going to be down on the
console here and i'm going to say oh
i'd like to play a little bit with this
praise package i've heard about
so there i go i say library praise down
on the console
now up in my source editor
i make a new object called template and
it's a template string
exclamation your repress is adjective
and so if i then call the praise
function from the praise package i don't
expect you to know this i'm just using
it as an example
it's going to create like random little
sentences for us
praising someone for their awesome rep
rex
so let's say i want to share my joy
about this with people using the rep rex
package
i would select this little snippet of
code again
this is the the long way i'll show you a
short way later copy it
go down to the console
type rep rex and hit return
and now let's look at the preview here
uh it shows defining template and then
my praise call
fails error and praise could not find
function praise and that's because
you don't have the library praise
command here
so over in that fresh r session the
praise package is not available to use
so here's something else you might do
you're like okay i'm going to add that
command then i'm going to make my call
to the package
let's see if that works copy
call repress again
i have a new error error and graph
whatever whatever
object template not found so
this snippet is incomplete in a
different way it actually doesn't
contain the code
that defines the template object
so here's the full snippet it
loads the praise package
it defines the template object
and it makes this function call so i'm
going to copy
all of that to the clipboard
re-execute replex and
we have made an exquisite rep rex
and so that's a little uh belabored but
when i
try to answer our questions for people
and i try to run their code
the two most common ways that i
fail are that they haven't
explicitly listed all the packages
they're using and i have to
either sleuth it out of them or figure
it out for myself and add
those commands or the objects they're
referring to are not available to me and
so those are the two reasons why i can't
run their code
so on the repress website
um i have a list of do's and don'ts that
are
distilled from a lot of other really
fantastic
sources about creating reproducible
examples which are referenced there
but the three big big high points are
you need to write this reproducible
example using the smallest
the simplest and the most built-in data
set
you can get away with and that is very
uncomfortable for people i'm going to
talk about that in a second include
commands on a ruthlessly strict need to
run basis so you really need to strip
your example down
and then i say pack it in pack it out
and don't take liberties with other
people's computers
and this is referring to making sure
that if you
create files you remove them or if you
change the working directory you
reset it if you change options you reset
them but basically
leaving things as you found them but um
i want to talk about so let's see here's
here's what that web page would look
like if you want to read it
more um but let me just
give a short example of something that a
lot of people
struggle with which is that they feel
like they have some big hairy data
object and they can only
show their example using it um
so tricks to know so the read csv
file you probably think of as normally
being a function
that you use to bring data sorry the
read the sd function is something you
usually bring
delimited data in from a file
but it also has a text argument that
allows you to inline
really tiny r objects and then also
just the data frame function itself so
i'm going to repress
using a keyboard shortcut those two
snippets of code
and see that's a very easy way to make a
very tiny
data frame either in line using read csv
or sort of for first principles using
dataframe
and then if you are a tidy verse
adherent
the typical package is what takes care
of
the care and feeding of tibbles which
are a flavor of data frame
and the triple function is extremely
useful
for creating tiny little data frames
because it allows you
to write it in this really humane
row-wise way like the same way it would
look in for example in a csv
file so if i repress this little snippet
you'll see very very similar output is
what we just saw with the base function
but it allows you
to inline the creation in this case of a
two row two column
data frame or you can again use just the
typical function directly
and so if you make a lot of repraxes you
get
you get really good at figuring out how
to inline the creation of very small
objects of course figuring out what's
the smallest object that still shows
your problem
is difficult and we're going to talk
about that at the very end
okay another principle is that the
reprax should contain code i do not
have to run because a lot of your
readers
have a great deal of our experience
and sometimes not always but sometimes
they can
quickly see the point without actually
running the code
but that is greatly enhanced if they can
see the output instead of having to
run it in their head and in their
imagination
and try to figure out what's happening
it's just much easier if you can
actually
see the output and so that's why i think
it's important that
your typical rep rex contains the code
and it also
reveals the output uh being produced by
that code
so here's an example i took from the
github
repository where the radar package
is developed because it's a perfect
little
example and it probably was produced
with rep rex
you can't tell and this person is just
reporting a
bug but it's like a great minimal
example
it says you know if the header in your
csv contains
quoted new lines you get kind of a weird
column name and you get weird data
and the fact that this person provided a
small example
and it completely shows the problem
i imagine is what allowed the maintainer
john hester who's listening to this call
to to quickly label this as a bug and
we've already got at least one other
user
giving it a thumbs up meaning they've
experienced it as well
and so um if you had only had the code
here i think you'd have a lot
less sort of quick engagement with this
issue
and so i want to show you
um yeah okay so code that i can easily
run
is very important we're going to keep
working with that issue
so if that person had instead
copied and pasted the output from their
r console this is what we would be faced
with
so if i were jim hester and i needed to
to reproduce
this issue and make sure that it's still
a problem
i have a lot of really annoying editing
to do
so i have to get rid of all the prompts
at the beginning of the lines
i have to get rid of all this output to
isolate the three lines of code that
actually do anything
so copy paste from the r console hits
some of our checklist but it's not great
because it's very hard for the next
person to run this code
worse than copy paste is the screenshot
uh so this of course does again
hit some of our checklist it clearly
shows the code and the output but again
if somebody else wanted to check this
and reproduce it
they actually have to re-type everything
which frankly is never going to happen
and so this is what i want to see in a
rep rex
because it can be copy pasted and run so
i'm going to prove that
to you right now so if i go to this
issue on github
and i copy i could copy all of this or i
could
as long as i get all the commands i'm
okay
so i'm gonna put that on my clipboard
i'm going to go
back to r
maybe to make this really explicit
i'll show you what i copied all right
that's what i did so i can
copy this again and call rep rex
and i get exactly what this person was
reporting
on github so i've been able to reproduce
it very quickly
from a copy paste but as you saw
reprox is like are you sure you want to
do this because i'm
i've got this output here
and so if you
if you really want to get really clean
code
from a rep rex that someone else has
made you
capture it and use one of the undo
functions in the repress package i could
use repress
clean and i'll show you that right now
so here's what i copied from github so i
could copy that
and call rep rex clean and now if i
paste
you'll see all the output has been
eliminated
and so i think that's a slightly uh
obscure thing you might want to do but
there are the full set of uh sort of
backwards
functions in reprice so it helps you
take
code that people have copied from the
console
or that they have already made a refresh
from
okay so we've gotten to essentially the
the meat
of the of the webinar now so if you were
really interested in basic usage you've
seen it now
and now i'm going to go into the shock
and awe section where i run through a
lot of
more interesting features of the rep rex
package
that i still think are pretty cool so
the slides show you what we're about to
do
live so i'm going back to rstudio
and i'm in a script called shocking off
okay i'm gonna
restart r just for good measure so the
first thing i want to show you
is how frictionless rex can make it
to talk to people about figures so i'm
going to load
the gap minor data and ggplot2
and i'm going to make a plot with
ggplot2 so you see it down here
in my class pane so let's say that
there's something about this i don't
like or that i want to discuss
with a colleague i can use rep rex for
this
so as usual i can select the snippet
copy to my clipboard
and run rep rex
you're going to see all the same stuff
so we've got a nicely rendered represent
includes the figure
but watch this um
i'm gonna go to a github repo that i
created just
to play around with i'm gonna create a
new
issue i have a question about
this plot and i'm going to paste
let's look at what we've got we have the
usual sort of nicely formatted
markdown and look at this
so when when refworks rendered this code
it made
your figure and pushed it up to imager
and dropped this link into your markdown
so if i submit this issue
people see my code and they see the
actual figure that you just made so
this is an example of one of the cool
things you can do that that removes a
tremendous amount of friction
if you're trying to have a quick
conversation with somebody
about code that produces figures
okay so we're going to go back to this
shock and awe script and we're going to
execute rep rex
many times showing some of the options
and different arguments you have so so
far i've only shown you
repressing when the source code is on
the clipboard
but there are a lot of other ways to
provide the input
so you can provide it directly in the
rep rex call
as an expression
so here you see that the assignment of x
and y gets done and we compute the
correlation between them
there's also an input argument that i'm
actually not going to demonstrate
where you can provide the source
as a file or as a character vector
um rex by default
goes and does its work in the session
temp directory that's all part of it
sandboxing all of your work but if your
rep rex
does for example file input and output
it could be much easier to force repress
to work
in your current working directory so out
file
equals n a is shorthand for that
so if i try to if i ask r to write
uh the first six letters of the alphabet
to a file
um without file equals n a
all of a sudden these four files that
repress needs to create
are being left behind in my working
directory instead of
um in a temp directory and it's
the r script that repress makes
it's the html
that it uses for the preview and
the markdown that it puts on the
clipboard for you
so all those usual files are left behind
in a much more accessible place but
you'll notice it has a
god-awful file name because we just
created it out of thin air
so if you want to work somewhere
specifically and
have nice file names you could also
provide
the base for that in out file
and now you see that it leaves the same
four files behind but they have a much
better file name
okay so so far i've been producing
rep rex output that's optimized for
github
so it's producing what's called github
flavored markdown
but stack overflow is another common
target and that produces slightly
different looking markdown
uh stack overflow doesn't use fenced
code blocks that use
an indented code blocks and
let me show you what this would look
like i'm gonna
pretend like i'm gonna answer my own
question on stack overflow
but i won't actually submit this but now
if you paste
that into stack overflow it also has a
preview
feature and it will be formatted
correctly for
stack overflow
uh you can also make rep rex produce
it creates an r script which seems sort
of weird but in our script that includes
the output as comments and that is very
handy
for pasting into an email or into slack
so
i'm going to show you the slack version
of that
so this is me talking to myself on slack
i'm going to create a code
snippet paste it
maybe i always have it set to r and
create a snippet
and that would create a little r file in
slack
properly syntax highlighted and again
people could copy paste it into r
and run it or
sometimes you just want to inline it
you don't get the syntax highlighting
but that also looks quite nice
the final venue i'll talk about is rtf
for rich
text format and this is a very
experimental
venue it only works probably on the mac
at this point because i actually have to
call an external utility to do this
but i'd like to show you this and in
fact it's how i made the slides
for this talk so uh we run a little bit
of code but now i can
go over to keynote or powerpoint or
something
and i could paste that in and i'm
getting rendered our code that is
properly
syntax highlighted and that is in fact
how all the snippets
in my webinar were produced
you can suppress the inclusion of that
little
ad at the bottom or you can include it
uh you can ask for your rep rex to
include
session info and uh for the github
venue it can be placed in this cute
little collapsible thing
so this is a great thing to include if
you think
for example that the bug you're
reporting could possibly be related to
the version of
software on your computer and i love
that it gets folded here
so then sometimes people include this
when they don't need to
and it's kind of overwhelming um so the
fact that we can put it in this
folding uh tag is really nice
uh rex can also use the styler
package to restyle your code so here's
a really i would say poorly formatted
piece of code
so by default uh rebrex trusts that you
know what you're doing and that you
you like your formatting but if you
don't trust yourself
you can explicitly ask for rep rex
to restyle your code and give it a much
more conventional
layout you can be silly
and change your comment string and make
it some sort of emoticon if you want
um repex is part of the
tidy verse right and so the tidy verse
meta package
can be quite chatty at startup and tell
you all the packages that you just
attached and if there are conflicts
between them
so we actually have a special argument
where you can control whether you want
that or not and usually you don't so we
default
to silencing it and then the last thing
i'll show you
is um rep rex can actually capture
input that in an interactive session
shows up in your console but it's
actually being sent to standard output
or standard error
so i'm going to um install a package
from github that requires compilation
this takes a moment so i'm going to chat
over it um but what you're going to see
when this reprice actually
renders is that we have captured
everything that would normally show up
in the r console
when doing this so the stuff that is
sort of coming
from r as well as the things that are
being sent
standard output and standard input
i was hoping that would be enough that
there we go okay and so
here's um the output of installing the
bench package from
github which does require a compilation
and so this is the part that's coming
through
sort of normal r channels and this is
capturing
um what's being sent to standard output
and standard
input so
that was a very quick live demo of some
of the more
i don't know if they're really advanced
but features you don't need in every rep
rex but that you might need before long
um a lot of the things that i showed you
toggling on and off
um you can actually set up your own
personal defaults for these things
by again putting some code in your dot
our profile which we've already talked
about
so this is uh just an example of someone
who hates the ad
they always want to include session info
they always want to restyle their code
they have a whimsical sense of what the
comment
um string should be for output
and they they always want to see the
tidyverse startup message so
these are not my defaults but it's an
example of what you can do
and the last thing i'll show you
mechanically is um
most of the time i do not do what i've
shown you
which is copying um code to the keyboard
and then going to the console and typing
repress there are two r studio add-ins
that
really uh accelerate your rep rex life
and one of them is called render rep rex
which launches
a gui i'll show you that in a second or
rep rex selection literally
refreshes the code that you have
selected and is
absolutely conceived for use for the
keyboard shortcut
and our studio lets you uh modify your
keyboard shortcuts
and so i have bound that add-in to
shift command-r this is how i usually
use reprox
and for example hadley also uses it a
lot he has bound it to something else
and let me go show you the add-in
so again i could select the
snippet of code that made that figure
and
launch the add-in and so this allows you
to specify a lot of the things that you
can specify in the call um by clicking
so i'm going to take the source from the
current selection
let's um target stack overflow
and yes let's append session info
click render and the usual things happen
and the usual output appears
down here and stack overflow doesn't
have
the capability to support this little
folding toggle so the session input
actually gets dumped in there and it's
full glory
so that is um these are
two other ways to
get your input into the refrects
function that actually are probably
more humane than typing it all the time
all right the last thing i'll say we
have i'll try to go quite quickly
because we're already at
45 minutes is talking a little bit about
the human side of making
reproducible examples and now this has
nothing to do with the retro x package
it's just about asking questions
so that they actually get answered
and i like this image because it conveys
somehow that you know we're talking
about programming maybe we're all
supposed to be acting like robots and
people often
seem to assume that they're talking to
robots but that there's a lot of humans
involved
in this process and i want to warn you
i'm giving a little bit of tough love
here there's
there's been a lot of although probably
still not enough talk of
of experts being empathetic to
newcomers and question askers but since
this is a talk
targeted at people asking questions and
preparing examples
i also want to say it has to go the
other direction as well
so bear with me for a moment here
but i need to say you know with all the
love in the world
sometimes people come with a question
and they have like a very
rigid theory about what's wrong or how
they should be solving a problem
but if your theory about what was going
wrong was so great like you
you wouldn't be here asking this
question right now and
this is the origin of why people really
want to see code
instead of having sort of a prose
discussion
because it's very hard sometimes to tell
what people are really talking about
the other uh life phenomenon i want to
link this to
is i don't know if you've had this
experience but if you've ever tried to
help for example one of your relatives
sort out a computer problem over the
phone it can be extremely
difficult a lot of what they're saying
doesn't really make sense
they don't use the words you're used to
to refer to things
you just feel like you can't really get
a grip on things and and this is
basically what it feels like when you're
trying to answer someone's programming
question
just based on english prose and again
like this is
why people constantly push you to
actually just show a small piece of code
removes all sorts of ambiguity
so um let's assume that everybody that
question asker and the question
answer is acting in good faith and if
they're
not then they're irrelevant to me okay
so everyone's in good faith
um it turns out that experts posting
on public sites actually are afraid
to post code that doesn't work
and so another reason why these people
want to see your code
is you know they're not just reading it
and guessing
most of these people are actually
running your code proving that their
proposed solution
works and then they post it when they
know that it's safe to do so
and this was a big like revelation to me
i really used to think
that the people i looked up to as
experts
just knew all this stuff by heart and
they were answering all these questions
just off the cuff
and then it gradually dawned on me that
part of
why they're experts or expert behavior
is that they are
constantly running lots of small
examples and experiments
so sharing your problem in code is
extremely fruitful
making a good rep rex is a lot of work
like sometimes you think i can only show
my problem
in my r session and i haven't restarted
r for seven months
and it requires the full data set from
my thesis
and that is in fact true it is a lot of
work
but you're asking other people to solve
a problem
and so this is part of meeting them
halfway but it turns out
you get a lot out of this as well so
let's be very selfish
um if you make a good rep rex out of
your hairy messy problem
um and if you reproduce other people's
problems
even reproducing other people's problems
is a real service and then sometimes
you're going to be able to solve them
it turns out this discipline it's like
playing scales
or um you know serving over and over
again like
you actually get better at programming
by doing this
and the last selfish point that i'll
make
is it turns out when you sit down to
make a good rep rex out of your problem
and you keep it self-contained you strip
down your giant hairy data set to the
smallest data set that reproduces the
problem
it is amazing how often you end up
answering your own
question in the privacy of your own home
and you didn't
have to make yourself vulnerable to
other people
so this is a great revelation
and i think the reason this works is
that when you have a problem it's very
easy to just keep going in circles and
banging your head against the desk
but there's something about preparing it
for other people and the rep rex package
is also
being a real hard ass about making sure
that your problem is self-contained
it kind of knocks you out of that very
unproductive
place and gets you back on the path of
actually working the problem so uh most
people
report this when they first start making
reproducible examples
is that it's kind of amazing how often
this
exercise means you actually answer your
own question
i will skip over this section since
we're out of time and i didn't think
people wanted to know it but it's here
a little bit about what's happening
behind the scenes
and i will conclude i want to give a
huge thank you
to yehuija and all the people who
have brought us the r markdown package
and pandoc the rep rex package is
just a wrapper around those things and i
mean that in both
senses like that is literally all that
it is
um so in some sense there's not much
there there but on the other hand
uh when i first made it and then
especially now that i've worked on it
more
um there's actually a lot more going on
like the friction that it removes is
is friction that is really important to
remove i think so in any case it could
not be possible without our mouth done
in pandoc
and in fact i should thank all the
co-authors of repress and there's a lot
of people who have contributed to it and
a lot of users who've been
extremely generous with their bug
reports and feature requests and
reporting how things work on different
platforms
so to conclude go forth and engage
in very precise code heavy conversations
about r
i'm going to take a look at the
questions now
can repress be able to also capture
variables in the environment and include
in the reproducible example
currently it cannot and that is very
intentional
um because we we really prioritize
this sandboxing um
i am actually contemplating basically
creating a back door for this
uh mostly because of creating rtf
snippets but at the moment it cannot and
that is intentional
um but you know i'm open to people uh
sharing
their use case about why that should be
but basically if you do this
um yeah
there are ways you could do it that
actually make those objects available to
other people as well but it becomes a
much heavier weight package so so far we
have not done that
uh oftentimes this is a continuation of
that question the issue is buried in
some part of larger code
and rather than going back to the places
where that data is gathered or
calculated wouldn't it be nice to grab
the variable mean current state
um again like yes and no
i would say extracting that out
is perhaps part of your job oh i'm now
realizing that some of these questions
have been answered
um does rep rex the function actually
check that the code is self-contained
or does it just generate a template it
just
generates a template so uh
the way you would find out that your
code is not self-contained is that you
get an error
um but it explicitly allows errors
because sometimes you're using
rep rex to show errors so no it is just
um it's on you the human to decide if
you're getting the result you expect um
does radar read csv support the text
argument as an alternative to file or is
that only in read.csv
radar also does this it also supports
the inline creation of a data frame
uh it does it through its primary
argument so
uh you would want to read the help for
read underscore csv but
in fact it's actually sort of even a
smaller departure from your usual use
i think i have another instance of the
same question which is could repress
help you package up an existing data set
and stick it into your data that
repress do's and don't document outlines
various ways of doing this
for example d put is a great function
if you have a slightly awkward object
and you simply cannot make your point
without using it d
put at least creates um a representation
of that that you can put into
a rep rex but so far you're right i have
not made this
terribly easy and at least the story i
tell myself
is that finding a really simple
object and making it um like is
intrinsically part of the rep rex
task but this does come up over and over
again
can you do a rep rex for a shiny app
um it is not
easy i think the shiny team is or has
developed
uh their own web page uh talking about
how you
create shiny rep rexes like and they
don't use this package
so now i'm talking about represses as a
concept
um let's see
can rex produce interactive plots
all i will say is i have not done so
um so i'll end on this question
um i don't know it would have to be
tried
but what i will say the side that i
skipped over
what actually happens so currently rep
rex
works by dumping your r code into a
templated
r script and uh
i have contemplated revisiting this
and dumping it into a into an r markdown
file
and then it would be much more
capable in terms of what you can do like
in some ways there's a lot of
equivalence between rendering our
scripts and our markdown files but there
are some key differences
and so i could imagine that the ability
to include interactivity
um is probably present if you're using
our markdown and could easily be absent
if you're using r
all right i think i will leave it here
and
include the webinar